foreign
economics
information
is
extraordinary circumstances in
foreign
[Music]
ukrania
foreign
a little bit
of Europe videos
[Music]
foreign
thank you
spells to Shield
foreign
[Music]
were you middle Scopes this morning
are you foreign
[Music]
foreign
today
well that's one of many
discussions going on right now I think
it's extremely important to to safeguard
the people that actually do enter the EU
are people entitled to do that we cannot
continue a situation where people
without permits simply travel through
Europe and and the two countries and
living on the circumstances that are not
acceptable so this is one of the
converging I would say uh views in
Europe right now that we simply have to
do something about that so I think we
can conclude a good package on that
we'll do a question here
I think it is obviously there are no
guarantees for that we and many other
NATO allies singers the villainous
Summit is a very good the good occasion
for decision making
we feel extreme strong support from all
the other NATO allies for eratification
final ratifications and I think we have
fulfilled all our commitments to to
according to the the memorandum but as I
have said numerous times it's only
trickier that can make turkey's decision
and we respect that so I I do hope that
we will have a process from now on on to
build news that is successful
for Europe the draft conclusions
a question from political Europe the
draft conclusions mentioned the need to
offer security guarantees to Ukraine do
you think these security guarantees
should amount to Nato membership well
for quite obvious reasons as a
still not being a NATO member Sweden do
not have any formalized opinions on how
other NATO members should should
include Ukraine but I think there is a
very strong commitment for Ukraine both
in in terms of the European European
cooperation and also in future defense
cooperation how that would be formalized
is another matter now today we will
discuss Ukraine's route to into Europe
and we have these criterias and we will
have this decision being made on how to
how to how to come back in late fall on
on their fulfillments so I think there
is a strong commitment for for including
Ukraine but there is still a discussion
going on how this merit-based process
will look like
foreign
thank you
[Music]
again
foreign
[Music]
solution
um foreign
foreign
[Music]
that's a it may Allah foreign
comedy
foreign
if it is
thank you
this is gentlemen uh good morning good
afternoon it's a it's a pleasure to
welcome back for that meeting in the
European Council you know that uh little
the European Union we share the same
values we work closely together and this
is absolutely certain that again Ukraine
will be an important topic on the on the
agenda you know that we are working on
the EU side to strengthen our European
Defense capabilities and I'm absolutely
convinced that by strengthening the
European capabilities we are thinking
NATO because because strange allies
Mason alliances and their events with
the 27 leaders today will have the
occasion to exchange views and to get
prepared for the NATO Summit because you
know that many European union members
are also little members welcome yes
thank you so much president Michelle the
Charles it's a great honor to be back
and thank you so much for inviting me to
the European Council and thank you also
for your personal commitment to the
Strategic partnership between the
European Union and NATO and this
partnership is extremely important now
when we Face a full-fledged war in
Europe the war which goes on in Ukraine
and I commend the European Union for the
support you have provided to Ukraine
unprecedented and also NATO allies and
NATO is providing unprecedented support
to Ukraine it demonstrates how we
complement each other we work also
together on many other areas including
on resilience or critical infrastructure
and we have a task force together the
European commission supported also by
the European external action services
and the the report is released today on
how we confer the strengthen about the
European Union and NATO does together to
protect energy infrastructure transport
in infrastructure and all the types of
critical infrastructure la last I would
say that what school the situation in
Kosovo also demonstrates the importance
of NATO EU cooperation NATO strongly
supports the efforts of the European
Union The Diplomatic efforts the EU
facilitated dialogue with our military
presence on the ground the careful
forces we have increased our presence
there and we call on all the parties to
de-escalate to refrain from any action
that can further increase tensions and
to engage in good faith in the EU
facilitated dialogue so once again
Charles I pretty much look forward to
the meeting today thank you what does
the Wagner mutiny mean for Europe's
stability and also how should you react
concern when there may be instability in
Russia in the future
the Mutiny we saw at the weekend
demonstrates that there are cracks and
divisions within the Russian system at
the same time it is important to
underline that these are internal
Russian matters and it's too early to
draw any final conclusions also because
it's not yet clear how many of the
warning forces that will end up in
brothers or other places what matters
for NATO is that we will continue to
support Ukraine at the summit I expect a
new announcements of Military Support to
Ukraine we also agree a multi-air
program to help Ukraine move towards
NATO to be fully interoperable with NATO
so we just need to continue to support
Ukraine and ensure that Ukraine prevails
as a certain independent nation in
Europe
sorry
after the event this weekend because we
we are in the we are together with the
European Union NATO allies have provided
unprecedented support and and we are
stepping up just over the last weeks you
have seen a new announcements from EU
but also from NATO allies of additional
support and also the training of the
F-16 Partners have started
I would like to see that what we have
seen during the last weekend is uh in
strong in contrast we saw the very
strong EU unity and NATO EU Unity this
is a very important Point additional
element the education is today to meet
with the opposition leadership in
Belarus they are also following closely
what's happening in this country
sorry
criticism that the EU
um punishing Mr President's prime
minister qurti and embracing president
budget too much I want to be I want to
be very clear we fully support all the
efforts made together with this good
cooperation by the high representative
and I would like to say that we also
support the idea as soon as possible to
organize a conference with some EU
memberses very active in order to
support all the mediation efforts in
close coordination with the United
States because we feel that the recent
months we have seen some difficulties uh
becoming reasons for escalation and I
think that the time is come to have a
global approach time is come to make
clear steps in direction of the
normalization and it's very important
because you know that on the EU side we
would like also to to do to do our best
foreign
security guarantees until NATO or Yahoo
membership should there be new security
guarantees for Ukraine well at the NATO
Summit we will address Ukraine's
membership aspirations and I'm
absolutely confident that the NATO
allies will send a very strong message
of support to Ukraine we also have to
remember that all night Dallas agrees
that NATO's door is open this is
demonstrated recently by inviting
Finland and Sweden to become members of
The Alliance we also agree that Ukraine
will become a member of the alliance and
we agree that it is not for Russia but
for the NATO allies and Ukraine to
decide when the time is right to extend
the full invitation for Ukraine to join
the most important thing and the most
immediate and Urgent task is to support
Ukraine to ensure that Ukraine prevails
as a sovereign independent nation in
Europe because unless we are able to do
that there is no membership issue to be
discussed at all and let me also mention
that this is also where uh where an area
where we see a link with the European
Union because of course the the EU
decision to Grant uh Ukraine candidate
status of course also has an impact on
the discussions which are taking place
within NATO
yes please
this is very clear and I would like to
repeat again later
this year and open discussions the
European commission will issue a report
after the summer and based on that
report on enlargement and based on that
report the European Council will take
decisions dividends of the Year probably
it will be in December on Georgia we
welcome the recent steps made in Georgia
and we will do everything to support the
Georgian efforts but we will see what
will be the report after the summer and
a lot will depend on Georgia the
implementation of the recommendations
will be key to to to to allow the
European Council to take decisions with
regard with Georgia by the end of the
year
[Music]
thank you
I do this foreign
[Music]
foreign
two main topics there on the agenda the
first one is of course upcoming will
will know Summit and we really have very
big hopes that it will be crucial moment
there we will decide on the clear path
of Ukraine towards NATO
we all understand that right now it's
not possible to talk about full-fledged
membership of Ukraine in NATO because of
the war but this is not enough this is
not sufficient to repeat the same old
formulas about the open doors of NATO so
I hope that they will make the
Breakthrough and in coming days we will
find the all needed wording rhetoric on
that
uh also very important issue is of
course continuation of Military Support
to Ukraine security assurances and I
hope very much that we will be able in
vilnus in close coordination to provide
this security assurances for Ukraine
Ukraine is doing very well in
implementing reforms and president
zielinski told a lot about the success
of legal systems anti-corruption
measures and they think that they
deserve a positive the conclusions of
European Commission in October and then
our political decision will be a matter
of time and they hope that December is
the most suitable date to announce the
start of negotiations in European Union
so few words about Belarus you know we
are the neighbor of Belarus and we are
extremely concerned about the
developments in Belarus and the
precaution is already there probably I
cannot say it for one by one hundred
percent but but this is very likely that
he is already there the fighter groups
or these serial killers I call them like
this they could be and emerge in Belarus
at any moment and nobody knows when they
could turn against us and then NATO
resilience NATO security and especially
Eastern flank Securities uh most
important element and I hope that we
will be able to take both decisions on
the strengthening of Eastern flank of
NATO uh what else 11th package of
sanctions is very important step and
step forward not very big one so this is
the reason why we expect
12 package of sanctions and I will not
be tired to repeat that rosatum should
be punished because this is just
unacceptable what they are doing how
um they are behaving threatening all the
Europe with the separation nuclear power
plant but of course they are responsible
for
numerous safety breaks safety standards
breaches in Australia's nuclear power
plant too this is the reason they should
be sanctioned and the ward of uh Ross
atom should be sanctioned to so what
else economy security
yes
well
I hope all countries Eastern flank
countries deserve fear treatment and if
they will be success in implementing
necessary reforms Moldova Ukraine
Georgia all of them deserve the positive
outcomes positive decisions I remember
our story our way to European Union
in the at the very beginning probably
there were different situations in
different countries but after after a
quite long period of adjustment of our
legal system we were able to become the
members of European Union together or
with other countries candidates so thank
you thank you
we have to be aware that any movements
in Russian political system will be have
repercussions on our security but I
don't agree because some colleagues some
sometimes say that strong Putin is less
dangerous that we put in I don't agree
with that we have to move forward and to
be decisive because now it's a crucial
moment of History if it will be not
decisive and United now tomorrow it will
be too late
foreign
Italian
dimensions
Tunisia
immigration is
generation you
Fernando consideration is
foreign
[Music]
de la
Santa Claus is
foreign
alive
[Music]
foreign
thank you
it is foreign
Crescent and famous yet
foreign
production
ciao no it wasn't English
um
foreign
information
from information
foreign
country
[Music]
foreign
application
[Music]
is equal to us
um foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
if you do new language
this is a new field of preparation
protect critical infrastructures and
it's good that the stall convert will
share this concern with us
then there is a
urgent issues
situation in Russia unavoidable
it's clear that putting
goes out of this crisis weekend
but a weaker Putin is a greater Danger
so we have to be very much aware of the
consequences everything
remains unclear what has happened who
where behind is a attempt of a military
upheaval or military Rebellion
and some generals has been over arrested
so I suppose that quoting will be in a
cleaning mode internally and a more
assertive mode
Ukraine has to continue being supported
the only answer that we can do to
whatever happens in Russia is to
continue supporting Ukraine and since I
am in charge of the European peace
facility I will ask the leaders to
continue funding it it's a good news
that we already have 3.5 billions more
not not only for Ukraine
and we continue our training Mission
almost 30 000 soldiers
this is our engagement we can study
what's happening what the federal is
going to do with the the Wagner us we
have to concentrate on our task continue
supporting Ukraine now certainly China
and Economic Security
China and economic security related
issues but
not exactly the same one keep in mind
that the risking at the end is something
that we have to do is our duty is our
job so it's not about China it's not
something that we have to negotiate with
China it's something that we have to do
knowing that it will take long so the
better the sooner we start the better
Latin America
I will debrief the leaders of all my
work on those days
and ask for their support to continue
putting pressure on them in order to
avoid escalation and go back to the
normal
the member State decided that the last
one in the first Council that the
measure should be taken economically and
politically in order to make them clear
that if they don't contribute to
escalation it comes with a cost
yes it seems it seems that put it is not
the only master in town and that he has
lost
for the state which is the Monopoly
Force Putin has lost the Monopoly of
force and certainly unstable Russia
becomes also a risk until now we were
looking at Russia as a threat because it
was a force and force has been used in
Ukraine now we have to look at Russia as
a risk because of the internal stability
we need that
we think about scenarios we need a deep
analysis that's what visual all
intelligence services at the European
Union and member states are doing
now we talk about security commitment
security commitments from my side it
means that the military support to
Ukraine
has to have a long call
it's not just the next 500 million
package it is not the next armed
deliverables it's something that has to
be in the long term
during the war and after the war you
have to make Ukraine able to defend so
the European peace facility for Ukraine
maybe it has to become an European
Defense fund the training has to
continue the modernization of the army
has to continue Ukraine's needs our
commitment to continue ensuring their
security during the war and after the
war
in relation with China
certainly we have to keep our relation
with China why should not we have to
keep our relation with China because as
you know our great investment in
economic relations are so big that is
impossible to think about the coupling
nobody's talking about it but certainly
this relation has to be based on an
understanding the ministers the Foreign
Affairs ministers approve a text and
present it to gimmick and now this test
will be used by the leaders to give more
guidance yes China's the three things we
said of rival as a competitor is a
partner we have to operationalize these
Concepts what does it mean each one of
them how do we put them into practice
but as I said the risking is not about
China
we don't have to negotiate with China
our day risking it's our business is US
internally to have first identified
which risk are we talking about
and secondly how do we proceed in order
to decrease this risk so this is our
world don't don't make others be
responsible for the our line our fault
lines is us to put a solution into that
I am working to the block
sorry
look on migration
I look at migration from the external
side
and external side
is related with the crisis
a Christ tomorrow
somewhere
is more migrants tomorrow
but it's a direct relationship between
irregular migration people desperate to
trying to reach our Shores put in their
lives at risk
it is the answer to some crisis Sudan
for example Sudan is a spelling tens of
thousands of migrants so our work in
order to fight against regular
migrations it starts by engaging and
trying to help to avoid conflicts
and to support Economic Development
these are the root causes then certainly
there is the fight against marvelous and
everything but from the external point
of view from my my portfolio
our crisis tomorrow is more migrants a
crisis today is more migrants tomorrow
so let's try to avoid crisis and when
one crisis erupts we should have that
possibility of supporting them more
otherwise you will have migrants
The Banger
nobody knows what's going to happen with
the Banger
but it would be good that the African
people
understand what has happened in Russia
they should breathe
the statement by portugene
saying the Banger went to Africa to
stall African people they did a message
from him that should be widespread in
Africa
thank you
foreign
Saturday
um foreign
[Music]
foreign
for some
different
nice Vietnam foreign
thank you
foreign